du confit de canard aux canards confiné
pour se préserver de la grippe aviaire
des milliers d'éleveurs doivent
maintenir leur palmipèdes s'enfermer à
la moindre suspicion les canards sont
totana zié au lionel candelon éleveurs
dans le gers
cela représente la perte de milliers
d'heures de travail ça remplacera jamais
la perte comme a subi nous sur
l'exploitation je parle pas de la partie
financière mais de la perte pour la
perte moral
la perte des animaux de devoir tout
notre travail parce que nous ces
quatorze semaines de travail sur chaque
lot d'animaux de voir tout ce travail
l'a jeté à la poubelle heures donc c'est
pour ça qu'on essaie de protéger au
maximum nos bâtiments même si pour
l'instant la zone de contrôle temporaire
qui lit à côté s'arrête juste de l'autre
côté du chemin parce que parce qu'on a
pas envie déjà de contaminer nos animaux
mais surtout d'en venir à aller désigner
des animaux dans les exploitations au
tour début décembre
un premier foyer de contamination a été
repéré dans le sud-ouest désormais 127
foyers ont été confirmés dans des
élevages français
résultat des centaines de milliers de
canards ont dû être abattus et la
cadence va s'accélérer selon le ministre
de l'agriculture depuis le mois de
décembre
c'est plus de 600000 canard et
palmipèdes qui ont d'ores et déjà été
abattus on a une capacité d'abattage
d'environ d'environ 80 milles palmipèdes
jours à partir du milieu de la semaine
prochaine
on passera à une capacité d'abattage de
60 mille cent soixante mille pardons
160000 palmipèdes jour dès lors que nous
faisons l'abattage des volailles dans un
élevage l'état indemnise l'éleveur et
indemnise l'éleveur à hauteur de la
valeur marchande des volailles
mais plus qu'une indemnisation ce que
réclament certains éleveurs aujourd'hui
c'est un vaccin il existe mais n'est pas
utile
ise car ils empêcheraient l'exportation
des produits ce que ne comprend pas
lionel candelon demain il ya deux
solutions soit soit notre
interprofession notamment donc le comité
interprofessionnel des palmipèdes à foie
gras
exigent et obtiennent vaccin donc on
sort notre filière soit on s'oriente sur
une claustration chaque hiver et d'un ce
cas là on aura un produit de très
mauvaise qualité au niveau du bien-être
animal ne respectera pas du tout les
règles et je pense que dans les deux
trois armes à feu hier sera complètement
morte
la visite de julien de normandie est
donc très attendue par les éleveurs
encore traumatisée par la précédente
épidémie de 2017
cette fois ci le virus se propage encore
plus vite qu il y a quatre ans et
inquiète les professionnels du secteur